bizarre avec entre autres acteurs michel
jonaz qu a fait qu'aucune là moi je
j'avoue oui je suis assez fier d'avoir
participé à ce film parce que c'est un
film après l'avoir vu que l'on garde en
soit longtemps vous savez on revoit des
images on se souvient d'une émotion
ressentie je crois que c'est ce un bon
film à saint fons ne s'arrête pas quand
là quand la salle se rallume valgarde
alors ceci le 20 mars au en fait dans le
film il s'appelle sylvain cap l'on en
fait mais il a sa mère l'a élevé l'a pas
fait circoncire elle a élevé qu'aux
événements en lui parlant de nouveau
rameau ils ont tué un nouveau ramené
leurs amants nouveau le rameau nouveau
et il prend conscience en fait pendant
le film c'est toute l'histoire il prend
conscience de sa judéité il choisit
d'avoir le sort des autres juifs dans le
film et il est déporté par les nazis et
sam votre fils lui aussi c'est ça qui
est intéressant dans le film c'est à
dire que lui aussi vous et sa mère lui
avait jamais vraiment parler de ça c'est
toujours le rameau nouveau et il prend
conscience de sa judéité il prend
conscience aussi de qui est son père
façon je crois que c'est une question
qu'on se trimballe tous quoi qu'on se
pose une au moins une fois dans sa vie
quand on est juif
ce truc de qu'est ce que c'est qu'être
juif que la question est les plus
brûlantes à l'époque de l'occupation
pour pour sylvain évidemment elle est
vécue d'une façon floue plus brûlante
plus dramatique je dirais mais elle et
elle est la même aujourd'hui pour pour
ça mon fils est la même parce que ses
parents lui dise un moment nous on était
deux enfants cachés pendant la guerre
dire quand pierre grimblat vous a
contacté vous et allez le voir il avait
lu cette scène et vous avez eu beaucoup
d'émotion ce qui est normal mais oui et
quand je vais relever la tête j'ai vu
grimblat avait les larmes aux yeux aussi
jean que évidemment la sphère et et oui
elle est l affaire était là vous avez
compris tous les deux en même temps que
vous ai pleuré ensemble ces stars les
deux cas et c'est aussi le cinéma qui
fait le lien entre ces deux ces deux
destins ces deux hommes mais surtout
pour moi lisa c'est vraiment un film
d'amour quoi le vrai lien entre toutes
ces destinées dont vous avez très bien
parlé c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
l'amour alors vous contrairement à nos
héros du film enfin aux deux héros qui
sont silva et sam
vous êtes toujours suivre aux origines
on n'a pas essayé de vous élever dans
votre famille chrétienne man etc
non je vous ai toujours su vous êtes
toujours eu ce sentiment d'appartenir
dit j'ai le sentiment d'appartenir à un
peuple
et vous saviez toujours mais vous dites
aussi ce sentiment peut être dangereux
pourquoi c'est vrai je me suis toujours
sentie juifs bien sûr j'ai toujours su
mais j'ai pas été élevé dans une
tradition religieuse au parlement le
chat bâtons etc
il y avait passé mais donc même le
premier contact que j'ai eu avec elle
c'est la douleur ce qu'on me racontait
ce qu'on me disait moi c'était c'est
douloureux d'être juif c'était les
histoires de déportation de ma famille
et c'est donc je dise que si j'ai dit
que c'était dangereux c'est parce que
oui c'est ce qui me c'est ce qu'on ne
faisait pas non 47 voyez ce n'est pas
très long grossiste qui est incroyable
en plus riches flammes le faut dire
lausanne et qu'ils ne savent pas c'est
fait le centre de tri pour expédier
voile alors tout le dans toute
l'allemagne c'est fou d'être né à drogba
y avait une peur un peu on le sait bien
que cette génération là qui est venu
tout de suite un peu après la guerre
pourquoi il y en a beaucoup qui n'était
pas circoncis il y avait encore il
c'était une des raisons 1
on sait jamais oui on peut recommencer
dans le film on l'a vue là c'est un
benjamin que je joue le père du monde
sait jamais ça peut leur commande y
avait tellement c'était tellement fort
est tellement intense quoi cette peur là
que voilà on sait jamais alors vous vous
êtes une famille d'origine juive
hongroise donc comme j'ai dîné à drancy
votre père était représentant de
commerce skema loi en fait du personnage
comme jouer en vrai il le dimanche je
lis écouter de la musique tzigane s'est
dessiné par manta on allait chez les
grands-parents et puis sortait le
tourne-disque là t'es pas appuyé ils
sortaient les vieux disques qui gagnent
hongrois et ça c'est vrai que ça a été
mon mon premier contact avec la musique
quoi pour moi la musique c'était ça la
musique ça transformait les gens
savaient un pouvoir incroyable quoi ça
c'était qu'au bout d'un moment avec le
vin et puis la belgique
en plus c'était quand même des gens qui
avaient quitté des rescapés de la joie
donc ils avaient ils disent il faut
vivre la vie comme un miracle parce que
c'est vrai car les actes qu'ils auraient
pu leur arriver
le fait d'être toujours l'avait toujours
en vie s'étant donné une force
extraordinaire force est donc une
intensité de vie et donc une joie dit
donc il ya en même temps une douleur de
ce qu'ils ont vécu ou de ce que leurs
amis ou leur famille ou leurs parents
ont vécu et en même temps une telle joie
de vivre qu'on passe du rire aux larmes
il n'y a pas de banalités on rit on
pleure mais en tout cas on est il ya une
joie l'homme il est pas là pour souffrir
où aller il ya une joie intérieure comme
si comme si c'était en attente comme si
elle attendait pour pourvoir un esprit
mais vous n'étiez pas se dévoile comme
vous l'avez dit que j'étais pas
religieuse c'est à dire il est vrai de
pratique religieuse
vous vous la seule chose qui vous
laquelle vous priez à l'époque c'était
pour avoir du bifteck turenne numérique
et puis plus tard vous menez une espèce
de quête spirituelle vers nous et
beaucoup cherché à les peuples à droite
et à gauche oui au début dé rabat
vis-à-vis dé presse des vidéos et
j'étais en inde s'était ramé alors
aujourd'hui michel vous êtes plus proche
de l'hindouisme des philosophies
orientales
mais qu'est ce que ce nom d'abord je ne
suis pas je ne suis pas
on a vu avec les ruines ferrer alors à
main suis intéressé par les
circonstances dans l'air les humains
dans les séparent proche mais non
j'adore parce qu'on appliquera ferment
leur image on a tous connu lorient à peu
près à la même époque
oui et je pense qu'aujourd'hui le les
pays d'europe et d'occident ont beaucoup
à apprendre la philosophie orientale je
ne sais pas reproche cependant elle
traiter de vieux baballe non mais c'est
exact mais ces messieurs robin doosan
prem's et des gens qui vous connaissez
ben oui dans ses formulations qui ont
euros ville pendu schaller mais oui
c'est donner ces gens qui ont des choses
à nous apporter
ah oui à sa beaucoup non mais je me
profitez-en la non sérieusement la vie
et à la télé oui je veux dire un truc là
on est à la télé on parle de l'isard
mena parler on va reparler accord je
veux bien profitez-en alors en cinq
minutes pour essayer parce que les gens
sont d'accord on est tous perdus dans
notre époque
dites-leur voilà pourquoi vous vous
pensez quelque chose à trouver de ce
côté là ce point d'accord qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une religion qu'est ce que
c'est que les religions à quoi ça sert
pour moi ce sont des moyens qui
permettent aux hommes des moyens qui
diffère selon les hommes selon les lieux
selon les périodes qui permettent aux
hommes de se mettre en relation avec
leur leur nature divine ça c'est une
question de foi mais il n'y a pas de
vérité là-dedans et à partir du moment
où l'appel où l'état est suffisamment
intense où le besoin est suffisamment
intense pour se mettre en relation avec
cette nature
divine intérieur tous les moyens sont
bons c'est pas les moyens qui courait on
s'en fout le véhicule quand on y va
ce qui compte vraiment c'est est ce
qu'il est vraiment intense ont besoin
cet appel à vers quoi faire quelque
chose que tu sans toi qui riche qui est
beau qui alors il ya des réponses
quelquefois avec cette question qu'on se
trimballe mais depuis qu'on est môme
moi je me trimballe une question depuis
que je suis môme il ya quelque chose
qu'on n'explique pas et quelque chose
d'autre et il ya des réponses qui qui
résonne plus que d'autres alors c'est
vrai quand j'ai rencontré frère robin
d'eau et mère et sa crème
ça a été une réponse forte parce que il
me parlait pas des choses en isme et de
religion est un machin tu disais il ya
une prochaine étape dans notre évolution
et ça c'est une vraie révolution en
péril sa pour le zénith et spectateurs
c'est que l'état actuel de l'homme n'est
qu'un des maillons n'est qu'un débat là
c'est pas quelque chose que tout à fait
qu'est-ce que c'est sur ce que c'est
c'est trop trappe si nous ne sommes pas
le sommet de l'évolution qui allait
sûrement pas et là nous sommes des
explorateurs quelle prétention de quoi
reconstruire exactement oui quand même
bien non mais voilà cette exploration
matériel et donc puisque tu m'as c'est
vrai que la télévision et de l'année
soit se servira à dire des choses à
valence conseille la lecture de mer et
en corse après montre bien sûr mais
l'être surtout pure et intense dans son
appel et danses ont besoin voilà on
n'est pas obligés de dire que les
conneries à télé bien alors un jour
alors j'en prends votre votre enfance
parce que c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire un jeu vous découvrez
complètement par hasard
et ça vous amène là où vous êtes arrivé
après que votre père était chanteur
enfin oui l'été en gris chanteur de
cabaret et que ses parents étaient
chanteur d'opérette
non un nom qui ravage l'est oui d'accord
oui celle ci ses parents étaient
chanteurs et vous avez en outre grand
père maternel rue du lac était chanteur
la synagogue que général inconnu voilà
donc en fait vous venez vous n'êtes pas
josé découvert que vous veniez d'une
famille de chanteurs simplement votre
père n ai pas eu deux les premiers y en
avait pas oui et c'est votre père qui un
jour à mener dans les années 60 au début
des années soixante à l'olympia vous
avez vu
dit place était avait décidé de devenir
artiste à ce moment là non mais c'était
un vrai choc quoi c'était incroyable
cette petite bonne femme
je me souviens de ceux de ce moment là
quoi ça et elle apprend la première fois
que j'étais dans un musicaux c'est à
l'olympia on l'avait annoncé le nom
d'edith piaf le rideau était fermée vous
savez à cette époque la lenteur et on
voyait pas les musiciens très comme ça
puis elle est rentrée tout doucement
elle était déjà un petit peu
c'était tout doucement sous les
applaudissements elle s'est plantée
devant le micro cette petite bonne femme
avec sa petite robe noire et que ses
mains comme ça elle a plaqué ses mains
sont contre ces cuisses et à la chance
et puis sa voix qui remplissaient cet
espace de l'olympia 1
et puis nous on était là que je me suis
dit waouh c'est quoi ce truc là sept
frères savez une force avait une
puissance la chanson je me suis dit
c'est d'être comme ça peut nous nous
bouleverser nous remuer quoi est donc
pareil j'ai fait un lien et puis que ce
soit la musique tzigane de mes
grands-parents et puis les larmes qui
venait je me suis dit la musique c'est
un puissant c'est quelque chose c'est
quelque chose et voilà est alors le vrai
déclic c'est en 62 on faisait 15 ans et
vous claquer la porte du vice et vous
casser le mot faut dire la vérité
j'étais pas de oui j'étais pas louer
puis les autres ne suis pas très sympa
goût parce qu'à l'époque j'étais un
petit peu enrobé 1 et alors on
l'appelait jonas la baleine suacot ce
bruit dans les petites classes un pareil
après oui jonas la balle des pieds alors
j'en avais marre et vous dit j'en ai
marre des il faut et il y avait un
problème avec le devoir j'ai toujours et
quand ça va s'arrêter
je supporte plus et là vous partez alors
on ne sait pas très bien fait de la
peinture du design la comédie exact mais
avec une vraie certitude que vous alliez
lui arriver si jamais douté de votre nom
car j'aime c'était alors oui c'est ça
est ce qu'on prévoit le futur où est
bien est ce que cette conviction nous
fait le futur je sais pas mais moi je
crois plutôt qu'on est un créateur de
sons de sa vie mais c'est vrai que
j'avais cette conviction l'a tellement
j'avais un oui j'étais pro bien l'école
quoi ça a été des années terribles et je
me suis dit la liberté et pour moi c'est
vrai que la liberté s'était d'abord ne
pas avoir de comptes à rendre à
quelqu'un ou un patron ou et caetera et
le truc artistique c'était voilà voilà
voyez avant de que la musique m'emporte
qu'elle me vrai avec des clins d'oeil et
que je me laisse séduire
c'est vrai que j'ai commencé par le
drame avait commencé avec moi quelqu'un
que je connais j'ai pas qu'il connaît
encore il sévit gonds oui
quand il est lemon c'est que votre moi
je connais bah oui m'a dit bon wagon
s'est connu à metz est assez connu vigan
quand même c'est un chasseur de
chanteurs de rock québécois marocain il
est toujours il est toujours la
diffusion en disant ah ben il m'a
toujours en ont seulement eu un jour il
est toujours au maroc il chante toujours
il a un droit je crois qu'il a un
restaurant où il chantait soit oui oui
ils nous regardent semeta pas connu ça
et alors après ou peut être le king
cette oreille toujours à votre copain
greg et après vous finissez quand même
par par chanter tout seul
quel homme
pour moi
elles ont la folie
oh oui
super
du balai
stupeur comment
on à l'oeuvre
avec
et quand les variétés
i
on passait la journée audi changer tout
changer
changer le tour
changez vous
en jeu
non
au delà du sangla et si du bon voyez
bras carpentier jeu témoin robert rozy
tout chez moi pas
perez qui nous souhaitons
que nous demandent touchés
est ce que quelque chose a changé
cauchon
non
lee ça c'est plus à payer
merci
je m'amuse
ça fait plaisir
le dernier s'appelle paul ouest
par paul weitz et le single s'appelle
c'est ça le blues
et ça donne ça
on nous
la pole n'a pas le talent pour eux tout
temps
et voilà c'est ça le blues michel jonasz
a extrait de son dernier cd qui
s'appelle paul ouest cas alors vous il a
dit vous êtes comme julien clerc c'est
dire qu'en fait les dents il ya aucune
pub pour un tampon gv ou non vous êtes
comme julien c'est à dire que vous
faites les textes avant les musiques
mans il ya beaucoup d'auteurs
compositeurs qui font l'un vers ce qui
commence mon égérie que les rituels des
textes et vous celle inverse
oui pour moi ça me paraît naturel que
c'est les mots qui vont faire naître la
musique oui donc j'ai avec la musique
est là pour exprimer ce que suggère le
pauvre exactement la façon de travailler
de de julien coeur du texte porte sa
rythmique en valeur voilà et les gens
font en général de l'averse bien et bien
voici avec nous